What are you doing for Waymo, cruise and Uber? Yeah.
So what we've done at scale is built the data platform for AI.
So AI is really built on top of data and these algorithms require
billions and billions of examples of labeled data to be able to perform in a
safe or reliable way.
So this 22 year old interviewed me for a full-time
position and rejected me just kidding.
He was 19 when he interviewed me and rejected me, that was three years ago.
And that was a senior at Waterloo. Well, in my defense,
they never actually explicitly rejected me.
They just go sit me after the interview, I'll show you the emails later.
Let's take a look at their old website.
This company used to be called scale API,
and it wasn't focused only on labeling trading data.
They built an API for human labor.
We're going to go back to August, 2016.
Huh?
I don't think that's it.
Ah, okay. That's more like it. So it kind of like task rabbit, but with, uh,
without the in-person stuff. So like phone surveys, transcription,
e-commerce tagging some categorization outsourcing work,
essentially. Now they only focus on categorization,
AKA labeling for model training.
So refined work.
The scale was funded by a Lucy gro and Alexander Wang.
Even as a name, looks like a startup. Anyways,
back then there were only two co-founders and they were looking to hire their
first engineer. So I applied here's the email exchange.
We had Lucy grill actually meshed with it on
Tinder a year ago. She didn't respond to me, but, but then again,
my opening message wasn't that great.
So apparently.
They stood out because I did a lot of different roles, so that's good.
As a startup, we look for someone who can wear many hats. Well,
that's good. They quickly hit me up with a take-home project.
Oh. Well, I mean, it's too late.
Now the project asked me to create posts, end points for them.
So their customers can send annotation box requests, AKA send images,
and then we,
or scale API will have their contractors drop boxes around whatever they want
and then send them back to the customers where they will probably use it for
some machine learning model or something.
So this project just focuses on this part and the UI
for the scale contractors to actually draw the boxes. Actually,
I think I still have the code for this. Let me whip it up.
All right.
So here's what I built so that the contractors can use to draw
boxes. All right. Let's send it some requests.
So here we see there's four images or four requests I'm sending.
All right. And then we'll see this.
And here you go.
So you could see now that you have a few requests and here you see a
picture of, um,
a few cows and here it says you have to annotate baby cow and
big cow. And then the instructions, it says,
draw a box around each baby cow and big cow.
So that's cool. So I think it's pretty simple. You just, you know,
draw them baby cow, baby cow, baby cow. Oh no,
that's not a baby cow. So, you know, you can exit out,
switched a big cow and then annotate the big cow and then you can
also, uh, reset it. You could also say it's broken.
I don't know if ever it's broken and then there's also the urgency here.
You could also sort by urgency if you want. So here you go.
You have urgency sort by urgency sort by date.
You could also click another one if you don't want to do this one right now. Uh,
yeah, I think that's pretty much it. So let me just annotate this big cow,
baby cow, baby cow, and then mama cow.
This will be saved in a database and send to the customer and the customer
received real, received these things.
And then you just submit and then you submit it.
And then here's another example. Um,
I think this is a picture of a K-pop group called the notes.
Okay. I, I know it's black pink. Okay. I know it's black pink. So here it says,
draw a box around the best black pink member and then the objects it's like my
bias. Okay. Um,
let's see. Hmm.
Okay.
Okay. And then, Oh, Oh.
Are you serious?
All right. So I think you get the point. And, um,
they also told me to use demean stack, um, if I can,
but to be honest, I wasn't much of a front end guy.
So I ended up using the men stack, you know,
very patriarchal of me. Um, I had some angler,
but it was clear that I wasn't really using the framework. Right.
But I mean, they said they loved it though. Um, but I have a feeling,
they didn't look at the source code until later on when it goes to me.
So no hard feelings though. I mean, I I'd go to myself too.
I would have been a trash employee.
What's popping guys. Here's a day in the life of an early startup employee.
So here's me coding right now.
So they invited me for an interview and, uh, Alexander does CEO interviewed me,
we just chatted. And then he asked me an algorithm question.
The question was a fine median in the data stream question.
He had to give me a hint for me to solve it. So, um,
that probably didn't help my chances. And, uh,
unfortunately he didn't respond to me after the interview.
And then as you can see,
here's my last desperate attempt after a month. I don't know,
actually, actually that was my last attempt.
[Inaudible].